okay so the impossible was actually a
film that I saw at TIFF there's actually
a lot of films that I've seen that I
haven't reviewed yet to come out way
next year but this film comes out pretty
soon so let's talk about the impossible
now I had a chance to see this film at
tip with you and McGregor Nomi Watson
the director in attendance it was pretty
cool it was a humongous sold-out crowd
in the Princess of Wales Theatre it's
inspired by a true story of a family
that was in a tsunami disaster in 2004
they were on vacation Ewan McGregor and
Naomi Watts played his husband and wife
couple that have these children and they
get separated by this huge tsunami that
hits the coast and from then on it's a
story of survival this is a very
visceral impacting movie in fact I'm
going to be honest when I saw this in
Canada
it wasn't rated yet and I was positive
it was going to be rated R but it's not
as pg-13 so going into this movie just
know this is an intense movie this is a
movie that you're going to see things
and it's going to disturb you it's going
to bother you it's a very good film I
don't think it's a great movie though I
think it's a good movie I think it's
very well made I think it's well acted
but there's elements of the story that I
think keep it from being great I'll get
into that later but let's talk about the
good the acting this is one of the best
performances I've seen from you Andrew
breaker there's a scene in this film I
won't spoil it for you of course but it
is just so intense the performance that
he gives it's so heartfelt it's this
conversation that he has and it's just
it's so well done and I was really
impressed by him in this movie in
particular Naomi Watts is also good in
this movie but she spends a lot of the
film very comatose and what I mean by
that is that she is very weak throughout
a large portion of this movie you really
get a sense from her that she is a
mother and she portrays that extremely
well she's very strong she sustained
some injuries in this film that I I
swear the theater just just went oh now
something that's really important about
this movie and something that really
needed to work were the kids
performances because these kids get a
lot of screen time quite a bit
particularly the oldest child who's with
Naomi Watts through the majority of the
movie I unfortunately didn't really feel
his performance was as good as it should
have been I think that it was fine I
think it was just fine but for the
amount of screen time that was given him
I didn't
think he was quite up to par yet now I
understand he's a very young actor and
he did a great job for his age for sure
it's just I feel like for the amount of
screen time this character actually got
for the amount of emotion this character
needed to have could have been a little
bit better
I was actually most impressed with the
youngest child who's with you and
McGregor throughout most of the film he
did a really good job the movie is
directed by the director of the
orphanage which is a great Spanish
thriller if you haven't had a chance to
check that one out that one's pretty
creepy and extremely well directed that
is definitely superior to this film and
I'll explain why the story of this film
is a little weak it's not that the story
isn't uplifting it's not even bad it's
just not quite great and to me it's just
a very well-done film the characters
could have been more interesting they
could have been more involving as people
and not so much just vessels to tell a
story in an emotional way by showing you
things that are disturbing and this is
sad and this is sad and the characters
could have been a little bit better
because to be honest I didn't really
care that much about the characters it
was just a lot of really harrowing
situations that were very impactful as a
viewer still as I said this is a very
well-made film it could have been better
in the script and story elements that's
really my main problem with this film
nevertheless I think the impossible is
definitely worth a watch
great performance is really amazing
visuals and some impactful imagery for
sure I'm going to give the impossible a
B thanks for watching guys and as always
if you liked this and you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
Oh